foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
this is the Ramsey Show it's where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your
relationships your work your dreams
I'm Ken Coleman Ramsey personality and
joined by fellow Ramsey personality
George Campbell Coleman and camel with
you never this sound like that yeah I
like the alliteration it sounds good
feels good George is here to answer all
your money questions and I'll dive in uh
on that and uh work questions we've said
for decades that your income is your
greatest wealth building tool and I
specialize as a Ramsey personality
helping you make more money and
experience more meaning so income and
impact so we team up together we always
have fun together we've been known as
the most fun you can have on radio is
that right and I do know that we got a
review James shared with us last time
that a one listener compared us to a
root beer float that's right that the
ice cream is good on its own the root
beer good on its own when you put them
together it's even better and so we've
argued behind the scenes as to which one
of us is the root beer and which one of
us in my life I want to be the root beer
I want to be a little spicy George we
don't get to decide Only The Listener
and the viewer decides that but let's
get to it shall we are you ready to go
I'm ready all right Jonathan is up first
in Salt Lake City Utah Jonathan how can
we help today
hi guys thanks for having me you bet
what's up
so a little background
um I'm a medical provider I work in
Urgent Care
um so obviously I went to the college
thing and during that process
accumulated uh a lot of student debt uh
the total damage was three hundred and
twenty thousand dollars whoa
um yeah it was just like MD what was
this what'd you end up with actually
actually a pa
um wow so did you still have the debt
so over the past year I've knocked down
knocked it down to ninety two thousand
dollars nice wow
yeah that's a part of that is uh kind of
the question I've had this side gig the
side business for years and years I
actually went through college teaching
Anatomy on the side and so we had this
little side anatomy lab that I was
working at while in school and it kind
of just put it along and kind of did its
thing for a while I mean it was somewhat
profitable but we decided to go on to
social media I think the end of 2019
beginning in 2020
created a YouTube channel and it just
went nuts after that and so what's
happened is I you know technically I'm
on baby step two still here
but this is taking more and more and
more of my time to the point where I've
gone down to about 20 hours a week
um as in my medical provider job in the
Urgent Care
and there's this constant pull to just
say you know what I need to go off of
the uh and Go full bore into this side
gig I think there's just a lot of fear
on my ends as far as how much all right
I'll tell you what we're gonna do George
and I are going to walk you through some
facts
instead of focusing on your fear all
right so how much money are you making
uh off the YouTube channel
oh geez that's so that one's a little
challenging I think because that's part
of the fear because why is it
challenging I mean you can look and see
what you're what's your worst month
what's your best month and what's the
average
um I think the average because I have a
business partner and obviously we have
employees and things like that but my
taxes for last year I think about close
to 300 000. uh that's what you made is
that what you personally made
yeah off of this YouTube business well
that was with the a let's see with my
provider medical provider I know I know
but I didn't ask you that I want to know
how much you're making what are you
paying yourself off of this YouTube
channel
um well probably around that two to
three hundred a year
um based on uh a little bit comes out
and just mostly draws I don't take much
of a salary every month
we kind of decide me and my business
partner at the end of like each quarter
or the end of each year
um
okay I'm still confused so let's let's
what are you making as a PA right now
what are you making does PA make about
80 000 just because I'm doing the 20
hours a week okay and so and so now
you're on track to make two or three
hundred thousand give or take a hundred
thousand on YouTube okay so you're
clearly making more on YouTube you are
paying yourself more from your YouTube
channel a good bit more than you are as
a PA true
true well so how much money have you so
so I you can make the move now
you know or you can say I'm gonna stay
in the PA job I'm going to continue to
build the YouTube channel and grow it
clearly the thing is taken off and
that's a serious amount of cash man
um and kudos to you
um so it's really your call here we want
you to pay off the debt so maybe you
stay in the PA position
and keep double earning there until you
knock out the debt and get through baby
step three and get the emergency fund in
full of you know three or six months and
then make the move uh but you can make a
case George that he could do it now you
know because you can always go back to
being a PA if for some reason you start
sucking uh with all the YouTube videos
uh YouTube changes its algorithm and all
of a sudden you're making half of that
but even then you're still making 150
Grand a year from YouTube alone and so
once this debt is knocked out your
expenses are way down you've been living
on less than you make clearly to get
this debt knocked out so I like the plan
because you said the fear is coming into
play of sticking with the PA job at 20
hours a week knocking out the deck
getting a fully funded emergency fund of
six months and then you it's not a leap
you're just taking a soft little step
off the dock there onto the boat
yeah okay how's that feel
um it feels pretty good I mean uh I
think my biggest issue was is like I
think I'm like there's growth that can
happen in the YouTube channel because
we're going into other obviously social
media platforms and things like that and
so there's this the battle was always
just should I I can do this faster if I
have 20 more hours that I can just dump
into you know the the job but it's it's
an irrational fear I understand that
it's like people in my life have said
you know you can always go back to being
a PA that's what I just said I literally
just said that so I don't think this is
risky either way
um okay we told you the safe plan George
and I agree on the safer play
um yeah can I ask and I don't want this
to be a big endorsement so if you turn
it into one I'll cut you off but I'm
just curious are you what are you
teaching about Anatomy on YouTube is
that what I'm hearing
yeah you know it's so I we started our
own private cadaver lab because you know
that's a that's a normal thing to do oh
my God so you are working on cadavers on
YouTube and teaching Anatomy so like
people are watching you guys do this
that's what the deal is
yeah so like we'll do a video on like
the heart and how the heart works and
we'll show an actual heart and obviously
we use graphics and pictures and stuff
like that it's kind of like the channel
to help anybody learn more about their
body wow that is fantastic very cool um
definitely not want to have a snack
while you're watching that no I was just
gonna say I wouldn't well there's riches
in the niches Ken and so if you ever
think you know what is there yeah you've
never heard that before say that again
there's riches in the niches this guy
this guy is in the niche I'm gonna zoom
into this weird Little slice of the
internet making a YouTube channel about
anatomy and it goes way more yeah than
he does in his full-time job wow pretty
cool well I tell you George this is more
evidence that higher education and
education as we know it is in big
trouble people are going to YouTube
learning stuff I mean it's more
interesting it is Jonathan's teaching it
instead of your professor oh by the way
it's free there's an interesting concept
wow all right George Campbell kid
Coleman together this is the Ramsey Show
don't move we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague George
Campbell we're here for you this hour
it's a free phone call if you want to
jump in triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five George I know
you know this but it's still pretty
impressive
the Ramsey show has been around for 30
years we just recently celebrated our
30th anniversary and we recorded a video
panel with all of us Knuckleheads the
co-hosts that hang out with Dave it's
like it's like Dave and the Ramses yeah
if we were a group family band all of us
yeah we take it on the road and uh so
all of us George myself John deloney uh
Christina and Rachel uh we all got
together with Dave and had a fun little
uh sit down conversation they caught it
with 75 cameras it was that it felt like
a press conference man it was hot in
underneath all those lights an
aggressive amount of cameras
beautifully producer James produced it
James are our uh our loving producers
such a great guy he produced it did a
lot of work uh and there are four
special episodes on YouTube filled with
stories from three decades and you can
check it out now on our Ramsay Show
YouTube page so watch the 30th
Anniversary panel it uh hit last week
and go check it out if you don't like it
your money back guaranteed yeah and uh
it's free if you say something negative
in the comments rest assured if two
things I will read it George will read
it and I won't uh that's fine George's
deep Neurosis I love it and it fuels me
Ken you he loves to read negative things
about himself no I don't know why that
is that's not it at all I think you're
great I enjoy it's like an exercise in
wit to respond with something cheeky
that's what the internet was made for
this is what the this is what you're
telling people now this is why you go
into the drudgery and the the dregs of
society other known otherwise known as
the comment section the only people
hanging out in the comment section are
people that are gassy and unhappy gassy
yeah it's got to be gas it has to be
Andrew's up next and Syracuse save us
Andrew yes Andrew is there in Syracuse
New York Andrew how can we help
oh hi Ken hi George I was just in the
studio yesterday and I appreciate you
taking my phone call Fantastic how can
we help yeah yeah so I'm 25 years old
I'm currently on baby stop number three
and
I'm looking for a career change I'm
burnt out of my job I've been applying
for jobs and interviewing and also
considering a relocation
um I currently rent right now I live
alone and I paid month to month and I
was thinking about moving back home with
my parents just to save some money maybe
to save up my emergency fund and
hopefully save enough money to make a
down payment on a mortgage so what would
this time period be how long would that
be to accomplish what you just laid out
so I could theoretically move in with my
parents I could probably
pay for next month's rent and then move
out in November and then hopefully I
would find a new job within six months
to a year
Are You Gonna Keep your current job
um yeah for the time being I will yeah
why wait a year to find a new job
well I I'm currently looking for a job
right now hopefully it wouldn't be a
year I think you're answering my
question on how long you would live with
Mom and Dad somewhere between six months
two years is that right
yeah that's correct yeah I mean I don't
have a problem with it if it helps you
save money
um and it's for a short season I'm not a
fan of you moving back in long term
obviously and I don't think that's what
you're saying but I've got no problem
with that what's your rent today
my rent is about twelve hundred dollars
and what's your take-home pay
um I make 44 Grand okay and so we would
you be paying something to Mom and Dad
what's that going to look like
um well I'm an only child I mean they
wouldn't ask for any money
um that was the answer I think that's
her I'm the only child like they're
gonna be thrilled to have you back yeah
when you talk to them about this or is
this is this going to be a surprise to
them
but um
I'm sure they wouldn't mind me moving
back in with them for uh okay for a
short period of time yeah I think as
long as it's a short period of time you
are paying a lot of rent right now
comparatively to your take-home pay so
it's correct if you are gonna stay where
you're at you need to get a roommate in
order to speed up your financial goals
yes that's right all right so is that
the big question there do we have a was
there another one about the work
now what you want to do
I I do and I don't you know I work uh in
healthcare my Recreation therapist I
currently work in a memory care facility
and
um I kind of know it's not for me but I
would like to
pay in my field
I'm also a writer I wrote a book and so
it's a very important book so what's the
latter look like for staying in therapy
um well currently I'm applying for
government jobs and hopefully getting to
a VA okay and um I would make a little
bit more money but not a whole lot more
money
so why government and yva
um just because it's
uh a better job than than where I'm at
right now yeah but I would think that
the that you could do much better in
therapy uh if I'm understanding the type
of therapy that you're doing it would
seem that there is a much better
opportunity uh in the private sector am
I right
um there could be
it's different things it's my job is
recreation therapy so I do sort of
leisure-based therapies for people with
disabilities to help right help improve
the quality of their lives well here's
what I'm going to challenge you to do
I'm going to challenge you because you
said I want to stay in my field and I
would say yes that's a good idea to look
at therapy in general but I would go
okay you got recreational therapy and
what are the limits there what in other
words what are the lids
in that occupation and then let's look
at other types of things where there
might be some additional qualification
that you need to get but would allow you
to climb higher and make more money I
really want to challenge you and push
you on this not just assume well I'm
going to go work for the government you
know and again I'm I'm
it's very hard George to advance in
government work it just is I mean in the
with the private sector this is much
greater opportunity the ceiling is a lot
higher over there and making 44 in
healthcare in New York I think you can
do a lot better A lot better so we're
pushing you a little bit uh Andrew I
want to get you in that house and it's
going to take a lot longer making 44
than 84. I want the bigger shovel is how
we use that term that means more income
and it's fast forwarding everything so
there you go well George
um
I don't know if you know we've got a
major hurricane
on the news uh hurricane Ian is uh I
don't know if it's made landfall I've
been doing a show it looks like it's
been picking up steam which is not good
as it's making landfills yeah so
preparers and thoughts for everyone
category four category five coming back
and forth I don't have the latest as we
sit here today right this moment but
it's making landfall and uh you know a
lot of uh a lot of bad reports saying
this could happen this could happen I
think it's going to go south of
Clearwater Tampa but I want to bring up
a leadership issue this is a very
interesting story the CEO of a
florida-based company
um by the name of boy I had that
postcard Mania okay her name is Joy
gandusa if I'm Hooked on Phonics and uh
she's getting a lot of negative media
because she told her uh Team uh just
days ago
on Monday prior to the hurricane coming
in she said if you want to leave your
home and you're being told to leave your
home and you feel like you should and
you have no place to go postcard Mania
is probably the safest place to be in
Florida wow it's a bold claim given that
Florida is a big State uh she said
anyway bring your pets bring your kids
bring everybody obviously you feeling
safe and comfortable is of the utmost
importance but I honestly want to
continue to deliver and I want to have a
good end of the quarter she goes on to
see oh boy there's that we got that p l
uh situation
she said um uh this thing is over hyped
and uh if it doesn't turn out uh we'd
like you to continue we'd like to
continue our service to the National
clients bring your kids to work on
Tuesday and Wednesday this week there's
always more hype in the media than any
storm has ever hit here bring your pets
if you feel the need I doubt that you
will need them nothing screams
productivity like Asher Aston and Fido
all hanging out at the office with you
that's not going to create any level of
chaos this is the last line from a zoom
she says we're not closing we are
working she goes we'll make it super fun
for the kids this is a nightmare waiting
to happen oh this is horrible I hope
they live stream it for all of our
viewing pleasure this is bad glossary
you gotta care for people
oh boy just not what a time to be alive
well there you go stay safe out there
folks yeah I didn't know postcards were
that big of it I know this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a Game Change injured so
head on over to netsuite.com Ramsey to
get a product tour today that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by George Campbell
Ramsey personalities and your hosts this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the phone number it's
toll-free triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to Memphis
Tennessee and Braden is there Braden how
can we help hey how's it going
good how are you
I'm good
um just got a quick question for you so
me and my wife um we're 22 years old
when baby step seven oh I don't have any
debt
um so we've been given a piece of land
um for my grandfather who left it for us
it's 100 acres and we're wanting to
build on it
um so I've got
20 000 in my emergency fund but then
I've got about 50 000 set aside for
um the build that we want to do
so I talked to the real estate agent and
he said
um we would look at getting between 250
to 275 000 for the house so my question
for you is
do I take out a construction loan to
build this house for 315 325 000 and
then pay it off and try and sell my
house when it's complete and that way we
have no hassle of trying to find
somewhere to move and live or do we go
on and sell my house now find somewhere
to rent for a year while we build hmm
what's your income
Mount 115 120. okay that 325 loan sounds
like a lot alone for your take-home pay
have you crunched the numbers on that
well the reason that I would do that is
because I would sell my house that I own
now and put put all of that money
towards it oh that's if you sold it you
would still have to take out a 325 loan
exactly yeah and put down Facebook oh
yeah that's so you're talking about
you're gonna have to put 500 Grand into
this to build this house
no no no no no
um I'm trying to track the numbers here
no no so I would get a construction loan
for 325. yeah put 50 down cash that I
have now and which would leave me with
275 roughly
um 250 and then I would when the house
was complete and it was transferred over
into a mortgage I would sell my house
that I own now and take that 250 000 and
pay my house off oh okay that makes a
lot more sense well when you listen
Georgia does I mean there was a lot of
numbers being thrown around I didn't
know how much the house was worth when
he said 252. I got you back back over
here Braden Ken's tracking with you now
we've got him caught up yeah there you
go all right I mean that plan sounds
good on paper if everything goes to plan
I personally would do that I think
George and I want to know if you poke
holes in that I like the plan because
the hassle of living and paying rent for
a year instead of just staying in their
house they're gonna sell you're saying a
year from now you'd have paid for yes
property
no it's already paid for uh yeah itself
yeah if I built the house it would be
paid for when I sold my house that's
what I'm saying he's gonna have a paid
for house in a year and 100 acres that's
a good deal yeah that's a lot to manage
what else is going to go on on this on
acreage here
um just well we have a lot of equipment
that we inherited as well
um so we just like to farm and family
farm I love it yeah yeah that's I don't
I think you're walking into this with a
lot of wisdom
um I don't think it's wrong to go you
know you're in baby step seven did you
guys get there on your own I'm just
impressed at 22 you have a paid four
house yes sir yes sir so I was
homeschooled my whole life so I started
working when I was nine so I think it's
made me start a house fund
um again so we were able to put down a
good down payment and then we had 80 000
um left and we paid that off in seven
months oh yeah it's even more you are
not scared to work yeah and disciplinary
and very disciplined I think this is a
great move I think this comes down
George if it makes sense financially
which I think it does uh this is also a
much more comfortable process to stay in
their current home while they're
building and not have to make all that
it's a double move if you're moving to a
rental what's that the only thing that
worries me is is taking out this
Construction own and then like which I
know that it probably wouldn't happen
it's just the thought of the house and
Market going down or something like that
and then I'm stuck with the house and a
300 000 or you know 275 000 construction
loan
um you know it's just kind of I know
it's probably not going to happen but
it's just kind of scary to think about
well I don't understand why you feel
you'd be stuck with it because it sounds
like to me this is the end this is where
you guys want to end up and be right are
you saying stuck with your current house
well no I just mean back in debt like I
just don't want to go back in debt yeah
but you're going to sell your house yes
I will but I'm just saying like you know
it's scary thing to to do and like what
if I get stuck with my house for like
six months because it hasn't sold which
I don't think will happen yeah the
market is extremely hot where we're at
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
blue oval but um it's a massive Ford
factory coming in about 20 minutes from
my house and so we've actually already
had a 275 000 cash offer but we're just
not ready to move so I don't think that
would happen at all I'm not as concerned
about that and we know the housing
market over time it's not going to shoot
down where that current home goes from
275 to 200.
yeah exactly but here's the deal my man
okay I mean the answer to that fear is
to go ahead and take on the
inconvenience
and go ahead and sell it now take that
275 cash offer and then go move
somewhere I mean you got options here so
if that if that's a fear then you have a
very viable option and now you're
sitting on a pile of cash and you're
adding to it while you're building so
yeah
neither one of these moves is a bad move
what's your wife want to do
who wants to stay in the house until we
build which is what I was leaning
towards I just wanted to make sure that
was wasn't unwise now I think what feels
unwise is because you guys are going
into debt after being completely debt
free but this is a temporary stop Gap
and soon when you get into this new
house it's going to be paid for as soon
as you sell it so have a plan happy wife
happy life that's Ken's Mantra that
worked out it's just good wisdom all
right Amelia's up next in Buffalo New
York Amelia how can we help hi can you
guys hear me okay loud and clear
thank you so much for taking my call you
bet what's up
so I recently refinanced my student
loans with Splash and I have 50 000 in
debt and 20 000 saved and I don't want
to be damned or Dave ramsey-ish but I
have a lot of work and life situations
going on that I just want to talk
through
um before I put all that savings on my
debt okay go for it how can we help
what's what do we considering so
85 000 I recently found found out
however that this job that I got 10
months ago the company has filed chapter
11 bankruptcy and so I have been
applying online to other jobs and I
actually do have a standing offer that
I'm supposed to actually go over with
the HR manager today but I just don't
know with that variable and I don't want
to move companies so quick if I should
hold on to the savings and wait till I'm
in a new job or just go ahead and you
know move that savings and and actually
pay off the debt what other expenses do
you have coming up other than this this
kind of job scare that's happening yeah
so on top of that
um my fiance and I have been filing for
his Visa he actually is from South
Africa and we're waiting for him to get
here and arrive so we have a wedding
coming up to plan for and then on top of
that I don't have any other debt like my
car is a theater car I've had throughout
college and I think it's gonna die in
like six to 12 months so with all those
changes I'm like would it be better to
take the cash and just park it in like a
high-yield savings account and not you
know keep paying the loan off with cash
flow cash flowing it but don't you know
use all of that savings yeah I think
it's wise to stock up some cash right
now because you have a lot of change
coming up the job is number one the
wedding's number two the car is number
three and so I think these dollars have
a priority right now and that's to get
you through this storm and once that's
over I just don't want you getting
comfortable and so don't go buy a thirty
thousand dollar car we're gonna buy a
reasonable used car to get us through
we're gonna do a reasonable wedding and
see if family can help pay for that so
it's not all on you we're gonna make
sure we have our stable income and then
once that's all settled we throw it at
the debt and get really gazelle intents
yeah yeah do you feel good it feels
right great advice Amelia you got this
got a great head on your shoulders
you're thinking through this the right
way congratulations take that new job
get out of that
um Titanic while it's sinking that's
right let's get off of that boat and uh
you've got this thank you so much for
the call all right folks we got to take
a quick break but the great news is
we'll be right back don't move
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman joined by my colleague George
Campbell we are here for you this hour
America we're taking your questions on
money uh and how about your work as well
uh in a toxic environment I feel like
you're being overlooked rejected you
want to move up make more money side
hustle income George and I here to help
on that Georgia by the way George is
obviously a resident money expert on the
show today but he's also very
entrepreneurial
yeah you are very entrepreneurial great
idea so we'll team up today uh on any
kind of work questions and money
questions as I've done them all okay and
I did Uber I did Lyft I've built
websites yeah you name it stuff online
it's great which do you like the most of
all your side hustles the Uber and lift
were not my favorite I didn't think so
you like flipping stuff that's fun to me
if you need an example of what you would
flip you go to Goodwill and you look at
things on the shelves and you go that
electronic let me see what that's sold
for on eBay and you go I could buy it
for two bucks it's selling on eBay for
25 bucks so even after fees and shipping
you're still gonna make 20 bucks you go
all right that's a good deal I like that
so it's all about margin yeah that's you
need a you need a uh a thrift Channel
there's enough guys on the internet in
their mom's basement doing that yeah you
see I don't know they're busy over here
I don't know these things I don't spend
a lot of time on the tube you know when
you call the tube it definitely tells me
you don't watch YouTube no one calls it
that I do and I also call Tick Tock The
Talk
it's a thing you would crush it in a
nursing home I I do it to irritate my
teenagers and it works 100 I love it so
there you go all right let's get to the
phones cheetah joins us in Orlando
Florida cheetah how can we help
hey um so I'm just basically wondering
because I wasn't babysit too so I don't
know if I'm in baby step one again
because you know everything with the
hurricane I had to um spend some of the
money because I don't get paid until
Friday so I'm wondering does that put me
back in baby step one
so you have you've spent money because
of the hurricane
yeah because I didn't I didn't get paid
yet so you know I was working on paying
off my credit card so I paid off three
three out of my eight credit cards but
then I didn't have money because of you
know paying off my credit cards and so I
had to dip into my emergency funds to
buy like water extra dog food okay you
have some supplies yeah okay so how much
money do you have in the bank
okay so we're gonna pause emergency
funds let's pause baby step two you're
currently temporarily back in baby step
one for probably a few days until you
get paid until we restock this thing to
a thousand then we're back at it
crushing the debt
okay so yeah I don't want you to have
any fear here are you going to be safe
from the storm have you been tracking it
I'm tracking it it's flirting
Florida so I would how quickly can you
get another 500 bucks
tomorrow there it is great and you've
already bought the extra dog food so if
you don't need it make sure you change
that budget too okay so not only you are
you uh replenishing your emergency fund
you've got that extra stuff that you may
not need that's true good point and it's
all you're going to use this all
regardless is there anything that you
would return if let's say the storm
passes I didn't end up needing this
thing
just like these little things of propane
that were only like 10 bucks okay just
wanted to see if there was any room for
you to go you know what I could get
another 200 back returning these items I
made sure just to buy exactly what I
would need if I but to only apply what I
would use yeah we would call that a
literal storm mode which in this case is
a storm right where you'd pause the baby
steps let's save up some cash to get
through this and then we're back at it
yeah so you're doing the right thing
yeah good stuff thank you for the call
Cheetah all right next is Daniel in
Phoenix Daniel how can we help
hi there thanks for taking the call you
bet
um I had a question about credit cards
uh so first of all
um my wife and I got on the baby steps
kind of dragged our feet did it our own
way but when we got on the baby steps we
paid off the debt pretty quick so we're
pretty much debt free
um we rent
but like I said debt free
the one question I would have about
credit card usage though is for my
employer
um I routinely need to make purchases
and then I turn in the expense report
and get it reimbursed so I'm agriculture
director at a small private school
a lot of the stuff's just you know odds
and ends plumbing parts I could do that
with my debit card but occasionally I do
need to do some larger purchases and we
just don't have enough really saved up
to to do that right now so what would be
your thoughts on the credit card users
to that kind of situation I would have a
school maybe another plan of attack
we're planning on their part yeah they
need to pick that stuff up and if they
want to do it by credit they need to
give you a credit card of theirs it's
that you don't need to be carrying a
personal credit card for this it's not
your responsibility and it's a
temptation to use it have you talked to
them about the situation
um only briefly I you know
some of the administrators and people do
have credit cards that the limit's
fairly low because they're usually just
doing things like
um you know buying lunch for the
students on on outings and things is
this a specific store that you're buying
from
uh I mean I got in with the Home Depot
Rewards program just yeah what they can
do is set up a corporate account with
Home Depot and that bills directly to
the school
um now the other thing is you know I'm
buying like greenhouses and things of
that nature
um you know it's like a five six
thousand dollar purchase this is a
legitimate yeah
it doesn't matter you keep coming up
with reasons why you need this credit
card
and I'm telling you it's the school if
they're reimbursing you then this is
this is silly for you to have to carry
this personally
have you thought about the risk
yeah that's one of the reasons what
happens if you buy a five thousand
dollar greenhouse and God forbid
something awful happened and this you
know some let's you know something crazy
happens and then you're stuck
yeah that's true yeah I know yeah what
we do here at Ramsey is if you are in
that kind of senior leadership you would
be issued a company debit card that you
would use for those purchases it
wouldn't be expected for Ken to take
that out of his checking account and
then get hopefully get reimbursed later
that's just bad business
so I'd have a conversation with them and
say listen I'm not comfortable with this
I don't have the money to make these big
purchases yeah and I don't want to go
into debt for this so we have to figure
out another solution and either they
make a corporate account the bills
straight to them they issue you a debit
card or they give you the petty cash to
go purchase it in cash so there's
options
okay got it probably sit down with my
business manager and talk about those
options then yes and and again you lead
with the fact that you don't feel
comfortable assuming personal risk
that's your language but can I be honest
with you Daniel I don't think that you
are leaning towards doing this I think
this makes mental sense to you but
you're like okay can you be honest with
us are you benefiting from the rewards
if you buy this five thousand dollar
Greenhouse
I do yes that's true but that's um I
realize how minimal that is so at one
percent cash back yeah well yeah I I
hope you take the advice I am not
convinced you will but I'm not either
it's the right thing to do for your
financial future
no it totally makes sense I kind of
hadn't thought of it completely in the
wording that you guys were using so I
appreciate that yeah I mean honestly
we're not trying to be you know use
Scare Tactics but this really is risky
George yeah I don't like that and these
are Big purchases oh my word and to your
point you know if he's having to get you
know agricultural things there's local
supply companies that would set up you
know some type of purchase situation
with the with the school the school has
a bank account I know they are a
business it's a private I don't like it
I think it's laziness on the part of the
school yeah they're like okay go do it
we'll just figure it out we'll figure it
out send us the receipts yeah yeah I
don't like that at all yeah you can and
here's the deal talk about the
Temptation Factor right because of the
points and all of the other things
you're sitting at your house one night
and here comes the commercial and
whoever the latest celebrity is what's
in your world Jennifer Garner is that
who it is yeah Capital One she's always
there there's something there's always
something there where they're telling
you to get your miles double this reward
this reward that and uh the temptation
as well I can put it on my card I'll get
a free vacation at the end of the year
right and so hey they're asking me to
buy all these supplies I'll keep doing
it no and if you're a business owner
please don't do that to your team it's
uncomfortable puts them at risk and I
don't want to work for someone like that
truthfully yeah I'm sorry all right good
stuff there all right good hour George
fun times time flies when you're we
should do it again sometime should we
there's probably another one coming I
think there might be another hour coming
up we'll see we'll see what happens uh
hey thanks to the team behind the class
who uh helps us uh stay on the air
appreciate you fellows and you America
thank you so much for listening this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsey Network wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
your money your work your relationships
I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me
this hour we raise some personalities
and we are your hosts your guides this
hour it is a free phone call to jump in
AAA
825-5225-88-825-5225 Tucson Arizona is
where Tiffany joins us Tiffany how can
we help
hello
um yeah I had a question in regards to
Life Insurance
so my husband gets 10 times his salary
through his job
but
we recently had a family member who got
cancer and ended up having to quit their
job and with that you lose your life
insurance so my question is
when you have employee sponsored life
insurance should you have additional on
the side and if so how many times your
income should you get I would also like
to add you do have a special needs son
so we have to keep that in mind when
we're looking into future planning oh
it's a great question Tiffany and
clearly that family scare has led you in
the right direction and you're exactly
right I want you to have term life
insurance outside of your employer for
that exact reason we don't know the
future of his career if he leaves one
day and that puts your family in a Lurch
because guess what happens if he leaves
eight years from now well now his term
life insurance is much more expensive to
buy eight years from now than it is
today
yeah and so I would get 10 to 12 times
his his income in a term life insurance
policy outside of your employer
regardless of how much he has with his
employer look at that as as icing on the
cake that's the gravy okay
all right and if I could just say
um I make my 13 year old 13 year old
listen to me listen to this with me all
day so I just want to say hi to Natalie
I've been calling oh that's sweet oh
that's awesome what's the name again
Natalie
shout out to Natalie 13 more 13 year
olds listening yeah that's awesome good
so you turn them into adults right there
hey Natalie your mom is a rock star
don't roll your eyes at her for at least
a month all right that's one of those
you go my mom made me listen to this
show growing up and now I'm a
millionaire with a paid for a house at
30 years old gosh so angry at you Mom
it's so true oh man I'm trying to think
of like this programs or things that I
like had to listen to It's a different
world you know what I mean you're
telling me you don't go home and force
your kids to listen to three hours of
you on the show today oh my gosh are you
kidding me the kids already think I'm
uncool and irrelevant well do I need to
give them more evidence gosh you know I
think you're so cool Ken thank you how
do they not see it
I'll help him get there George one of
these days you're gonna have some little
camels and then they're gonna be
medium-sized camels and they're going to
no longer think you're cool no matter
what you do I heard Will Ferrell's
family doesn't think he's funny and that
gave me great peace I heard that
interview I think that was with
um forget what podcast that was on maybe
the armchair
he did say that he says my kids don't
think I'm funny and I almost pulled the
car over on that one I was like how can
you not think that Will Ferrell's funny
but the the positive of this is no
matter what we get we're very blessed to
get to do things very publicly and
people say nice things about us
um and and but when you go home humility
is there for waiting for you yes at home
yeah I've had people ask on podcasts
before like how do you stay grounded I
have three teenagers nothing will ground
a person that's dealing with teenage
problems George they are like human
gravity to you Kevin just keep you on
this Earth I'll tell you what they are
they're human human sinking funds oh
that's true recent data came out you
know how much it cost to raise a kid now
have you seen this this was it was it
three hundred thousand dollars is what
they're 17 18 years old to 18 years of
age it's gonna cost you 300 Grand per
kid if that's not a reason to do these
baby steps I don't know what is I I
that's why I bring it up that's per kid
per kid three kids that's a million
bucks do you need to step out right now
and call Whitney I'm having some heart
palpitations second thoughts I thought
how much is a French Bulldog French
Bulldogs are probably close to that they
are born broken and very needy goodness
gracious born broken born broken you are
gonna get hate mail for that because
there are a bunch of French Bulldog
loving clubs out there that are gonna
come out you know what happens when you
when you're you know purebred no you
know what that means what you kept it in
the family and things start to go
Haywire in the gene pool there so
they're born with you know hip dysplasia
they've got a spine issues really both
of your dogs flat faces the brachial the
breathing issues well everybody loves
the faces are both of your dogs broken
are they okay they're fine they got a
clean bill if they have their issues but
don't we all
well it's fine all right we're doing
thanks for checking in Austin all right
hey we're taking your phone calls all
right money calls maybe it's about
paying for your dog's bills right we
need more calls about dog ownership we
need more calls about dogs and and
animals and things of that nature uh
let's get to the phones Huntsville
Alabama is where Tyler is Tyler how can
we help
hey how's it going guys well we're
having a blast here Tyler what's up
that's awesome so uh me and my wife are
sort of wondering we um finished our
baby steps did Financial Peace
University but I guess we're on our last
step and that's what do we do with our
mortgage so we just had our first kid
about two months ago oh congrats
thank you thank you he's a fine young
man
um so we're we're trying to we know we
um we know we're gonna move the next
three to five years uh our school zone
isn't the best
um but we live in a great neighborhood
and everything
uh we're just kind of wondering do we
snowball our mortgage or do we just
continue putting in savings
how much money do you have in the bank
so we have about 40 000 in savings so
that's plenty that's probably beyond
your six-month emergency fund
we'll be on the six months I would use
any of the extra money to throw at the
mortgage and pay this thing down what's
left on the mortgage
250 okay and what's your income
uh 100
Bond give or take love it so the
question is more how many years would it
take making 170 to pay off 250.
so we averaged it up we're putting about
3 000 a month in savings so what are you
saving for
that's a great question you know uh I
ask her that all the time
so Mama's deciding where the money's
going is this a security gland flare-up
is that what's happening she's going we
need more money we need more money what
if something happens yeah it well when
she got started with the baby steps it
it kind of just it spiraled out of
control we we became real conservative
with our money we started doing
everything and that's just the way life
became
um you know we got everything we wanted
things I'd love a new truck but you know
we we vowed never to go back in debt
over a vehicle again well you can pay
cash for a truck
yeah and that's that then they come so
with the newborn um I've got a
forerunner and it's great
um it's newer it won't have no issues
and May hopefully last forever but she's
got a small Jeep and it is not um a
kid-friendly vehicle so well that's a
great Mama's vehicle yeah that's what
we're looking at there we go so that's
part of it you know we balance these
things out we don't have to put every
dollar onto the mortgage we have to look
at what our upcoming goals are in life
and part of that is upgrading the cars
and so let's do that and start attacking
the mortgage and how cool would it be
three to five years from now when you
move you have a paid for a house and you
roll all of that Equity into the next
one or maybe even pay cash start
dreaming about that with your wife and I
think that will give her a little bit of
Peace about the future and you never
know what's going to happen three to
five years from now so it's always a
good strategy to keep paint on the house
after you take care of these vehicle
needs and stuff like that so
congratulations Tyler he seemed
remarkably rested for a man with a 10
month old I was impressed but as he said
he has a fine young man there's fine
young man congratulations on that hey
don't move more Ramsay show right around
the corner
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk about your life your money your
work your relationships
he's George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman
we're together for you this hour the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five
uh George we've met thousands of people
in our time here yeah and it's a
pleasure to work with people and we've
talked to thousands of people on air and
uh it's always amazing when people have
Great accomplishments like losing a
bunch of weight or finding that dream
job or overcoming mental health issues
and moving forward and uh that's why we
love our smart conference where we have
a full day where we look at all of those
areas of life and bring people
transformational content uh the next
smart conference very exciting it's
going to be here before we know it
George Dallas Texas Saturday October 22.
less than a month away wow are you
wearing a cowboy outfit or anything I
can't give any spoilers but there's
going to be some fun things besides all
of the great content it's our most
entertaining event we do it really is
the most breadth of contest yeah Ramsay
personalities Rachel Cruz Dr John
deloney George Campbell Dave Ramsey
myself uh all on the stage to give you a
smart plan for your money your career
your personal growth your relationships
uh join us live in person October 22 get
your tickets before they sell out
ramseysolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats today are we allowed to talk
about one of the things that we're going
to be doing as a group all of us
together oh we can tease it I don't even
know if it's official but I like teasing
it speak it into existence what are they
going to do I don't know don't do that
again Ken I mean the team involved is
not listening right they're not
listening so we're safe well we're going
to be we're going to be having a moment
a recreation of a very well-known game
show is that enough I could leave it at
that one of the most popular
long-standing uh game shows we're going
to bring it live all the Ramsey
personalities together on the stage
smart conference how about that we're
set up I can the guys in the booth don't
even care they're not listening at all
James could care less that wasn't even
close to controversy he's muted Us by
now yeah he absolutely he's running he's
running the best of right now we don't
even know what's happening uh all right
back to the phones we go Seattle
Washington is where Sydney joins us
Sydney how can we help
hi guys thank you so much
taking off YouTube root beer float there
it is there it is Sydney Sydney may I
ask uh is George the vanilla ice cream
or the root beer or or am I well the
root for how you break that down
I say you are the vanilla ice cream
there we go that's what I called it Ken
you're so smooth I I we won't spend any
more time on it but she has spoken the
fans have spoken and things would go
forward Sydney thank you for that how
much how can we help you actually how
can we help today okay so
um just given the background I'll give
you guys in a minute I would like to
know if I should
sell my car and downgrade and add some
of that money towards my upgrading my
husband's car
so we we just finished a baby step
number three as of last month congrats
um thank you so everything is all paid
for
um so we're on baby steps four five six
now
um and our net income is about 240
000 a year wonderful yeah yeah so but
given that and now you know I want to be
intentional with our money so saving up
for vacations and things like that in
our baby steps four five six
um but now I don't know if I should sell
my car and downgrade my car and get him
a better car because he's had his car
since 2011.
um it's running fine but it's been
having a lot of problems so we have to
fix it a few times now and it's time for
an upgrade and now Sydney hit me
straight here what's your car worth and
it's paid for you said my car if I if I
sell it now when I look it up until it
books it's about 45 000. well for your
income it doesn't sound like this is an
issue you have twenty thousand dollars
coming in of take-home pay every month
right so I would rather you take control
yes it's not worth selling your car
that's your car is not the issue
okay so that was just a patient issue
yeah how much of the 20 can we now set
aside for his upgrade car
five ten thousand a month 15 000 a month
right well which one like what is the
amount that you're thinking uh that you
guys need to spend to upgrade his car
um if we sell his car we'll probably get
like 3 000 so I want to maybe like 30
000 cars right let's have that be the
goal how quickly can we save up thirty
thousand dollars making twenty thousand
a month
the answer is a couple months
right yeah
but I want to favor vacations and things
well you can do that with that with
sinking fun in your budget are you going
on vacation next month or six months
from now no
probably more than that okay so let's
say we want ten thousand dollars six
months from now we divide ten by six and
that gives us our number we need to save
each month
and by the way once you save up and buy
this car you've now freed up all that
money you were saving to go towards
other goals
that's true so this is a non-issue with
your income if you were making 2 000 a
month versus 20 it would be a different
conversation you guys have an amazing
shovel that all of your goals will
happen very quickly because of that
okay
you're so used to being in the pipe
budget that is like oh what do we do now
we move from intense to intentional once
you get to baby step four and that's
what you guys are doing so still follow
a budget to a t every month allocate
those dollars and the goals will change
each month depending on what's Happening
but those sinking funds should give you
peace that you're not going to wake up
and go we don't have money for a
vacation all of a sudden yeah you got
this Sydney and congratulations on the
discipline the diligence to get where
you are now it's just a slight change
not in the discipline but in the Outlook
and and you guys can do this so you're a
nice car my goodness uh but what a what
a nice lady willing to downright her car
for the house wow
would Stacy do that I wouldn't want her
to yeah agreed I wouldn't want her to I
think the wives should always drive the
nicer car the personal stance I have oh
that would be true in our marriage it
was now we're in a situation we both
have you know nice cars but it was
always like she was the one you know and
still is you know if she's the key Uber
driver of the Coleman house oh yeah so
you know you got they got friends you
know but as we've said before on the
show
uh when you have kids and there's I I
want to park here for a second because
we get this call on a regular basis so
people feel this pressure to have a
super nice super new fancy car when kids
start arriving oh yeah under the guise
of safety and reliability right which
you know a 10 year old car there's the
you know besides the 47 airbags I'm sure
they could prove and point to but but
the point I always try to make with
people is
once those kids are toddlers And they
start getting snacks like goldfish and
Mott's applesauce and all that stuff
that's everywhere you're super nice
fancy new car everything's just sticky
nothing more than a dumpster on Wheels
okay this is I'm not trying to scare
kids uh scare people out of kids but
they're scaring me right now as an OCD
you know clean freak are you aware of
how much a kid can destroy a car in a
two-hour road trip with the little uh oh
the fruit uh the Fruit Chews uh on a
summer day they drop them in the car you
you go out I'm gonna have plastic for
the car just so I can just grab it all
and throw it away after the road right
so if I've hacked so my point is this
if I'm working through the baby steps
I'm gonna get the most affordable budget
conscious car possible that is
Dependable it gets us from A to B
because the kids are going to destroy
the interior of the car anyway but don't
go into debt on a depreciating asset
under the guise of reliability and o4
Corolla is about as reliable as it gets
it is the truth is they just want to
look good yeah while they're at it yeah
didn't you drive a Corolla I had a Civic
an 09 Civic until a few months ago yeah
I love that car what is the uh uh brand
maker of the Corolla uh Toyota there it
is George you've come a long way I'm
learning folks uh six months ago he
would have said Toyota and the team made
fun of me because of my speech
impediment I guess
hey that you do not don't you do that
you don't have an impediment you just
didn't know my parents aren't from this
country Ken oh boy I'm pulling that card
now hey I'm out I'm backing away slowly
caramel or caramel
uh caramel
close enough yeah there it is hey
those searing topics plus your calls
coming up don't move this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
the conversation here on the ranger show
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
George Campbell we're here together for
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's get back to the
phones Bonnie joins us now in Huntington
Beach California Bonnie how can we help
hey guys thank you for taking my call I
just have a quick question hopefully
I've been using the monthly budget
um app and I just want to make sure I'm
using this correctly I can use it for
about three months
um are you talking about every dollar
our budgeting app yeah okay cool you got
it just want to make sure and yeah no
problem and I got the um I able to
allocate every dollar for each month
that I'm expecting to receive as well as
allocate to each bill however my
question is what about the the money
that is there from the prior month am I
there shouldn't be any extra money
that's not being allocated correct yes
you want it to be equal zero income
minus expenses equals zero so you're
saying you are under budget in certain
categories and that creates a surplus
that's where I'm you
bills are going to be allocated for
every dollar and then I budget for every
category but there's other money around
that I'm not sure so what categories do
you have Surplus in for example are you
budgeting 200 for groceries but you're
spending 150 by the end of the month and
that leaves a 50 Surplus
no actually so so I do that but it seems
like I need to make sure because I'm
only budgeting what I'm expecting as far
as income goes so are you getting more
income than you think
there could be just residual money
that's been sitting there from prior
months that's what I'm thinking okay
well you can allocate that to your next
goal so put a line item in your budget
and throw that at your debt or where are
you at in the baby steps are you paying
off debt I yes I'm beta step two great
well it's a good problem to have to have
too much money versus not enough at the
end of the month
so I would take that chunk of money and
throw it at the debt and you can put
that in your budget line item as debt
payoff
full total of what I have in my account
and then budget every dollar because I'm
just doing what I'm expecting as far as
income comes in
well do it based on what actually ends
up in your bank account so if you budget
a thousand dollars for your check and
it's a thousand and twenty well you can
go in and adjust your line item for that
piece of income
got it so it's that simple yeah but
you're doing great I love that you're so
hyper focused and got this budget dialed
in that tells me that you are gazelle
intense and that this debt's going to be
paid off yeah way to go really awesome
she gets on her way and it takes about
three months to get that budget dialed
in so don't give up if you do it for a
month and you go oh I messed it up guess
I'm not meant for budgeting yeah and I
like what you said you got to remember
that the budget is a um it's not an
immovable object it's a flexible you
know so if something changes we have to
change the budget exactly all with the
eye of making sure that we aren't
spending more than is coming in so great
stuff Bonnie appreciate the call Abby's
up next in Phoenix Arizona Abby how can
we help
hi so my boyfriend and I went to see you
guys when you guys came back in like
September 12th oh great um Building
Wealth fun times thanks for coming it
was it was definitely a good time but
um and so he is the financial Guru
between the two of us and so we're
talking
he doesn't have any day
so we're trying to get mine under
control and the subject of the 401K came
up and I told him I was contributing 10
percent and so he told me like until my
debt is under control we need to stop
with contributing to my 401k he said you
know it's fine so right now zero percent
you know until we get it done and so I
changed it and then I got a second
opinion for my brother and he said he's
like well they match four percent why
don't you just continue to put in that
four percent like you haven't seen it
anyway because you were at 10 it's not
going to make that big of a difference
so I'm curious why go for the second
opinion did you agree with your
boyfriend because it sounds like you
just disagreed and you wanted someone to
validate what you think you should do
I honestly didn't know like what was the
best option but
he my boyfriend has had the same thing
where he said like no like zero percent
of the way go until we finished
everything but if you feel four percent
is what you need to do then scientific
he's like this is going to continue to
allocate and we're going to drag around
as possible even more oh I I get it and
you know if you look to the culture you
get culture-like results and we're all
about living counter-culturally and so
you're right it sounds crazy to go zero
percent when you get the four percent
match it's free money right that's what
you're thinking and that's what your
brother thinks and he's not a stupid guy
and you can do that but you're not going
to get out of debt as fast as if you
pause to go down to zero and it puts a
fire under your butt because guess what
you want to go back to investing don't
you
yeah and so what does that do it fuels
your debt-free journey because now
you're extra excited to get back to
investing plus you have a bigger pile of
money to throw at the debt
great
so you can do your plan and live your
truth but we have a plan that's worked
for 10 million people and I would
encourage you to follow your boyfriend's
advice in this regard and go to zero
percent for a short period of time so
how long is it going to take to pay off
your debt if you went to zero percent
uh if I stay Cooper and it's all focused
in by next December next December so
we're talking a little over a year
you'll be completely debt free will you
have a fully funded emergency fund or is
that going to be another six months
after that
and now I'm fully funded do you have a
are you working full-time
yeah well uh have you considered having
a part-time job maybe adding 20 25 hours
a week to make even more money to make
that December next year turn into maybe
summer
maybe less
um I can pick up extra shifts at work
until I start to do that
and see like how much more we can add to
it so good I love it allocated it to
them just consider that yeah okay yeah
set an aggressive goal and say a year
from now I want to be debt free with a
fully funded emergency fund and I want
to get back to investing and when I do
it's not going to be 10 it's going to be
15 percent
and that money compounded as a young
woman over the course of your career man
you're going to be in great shape
so this is the one time I say I agree
with the boyfriend it's pretty rare on
this show oh really do you have a
pattern of calls where you don't agree
with the boys sometimes the boyfriends
you know like they can be Knuckleheads
but this guy's got a good head on his
shoulders so keep him around yeah he's
paying attention to the Ramsay plan she
kept saying we which were I thought they
had a little more finances but it sounds
like he's just kind of acting as a
financial coach yeah I'll tell you what
I think he's doing I think he's playing
the long game
that's what I think you take a girl to a
Ramsay event next thing you know you put
a ring on it that's how it works I think
he's going before I put a ring on it I
want to make sure that she uh takes care
of my voice uh you know let's get rid of
the debt I think this guy's a very very
smart young man because we know that
money issues contribute to a lot of
divorce right if you see you don't see
items money problems money fights one of
the top causes of divorce yeah you know
what's encouraging Ken at The Building
Wealth events we did all over the
country but especially in Phoenix was
how many young people there were I did
notice that our crowds tend to be you
know we're talking late 20s 30s 40s 50s
60s there were so many people in their
20s who have been listening for years
yeah and it gave me great great faith in
the current Generations the next ones
there are some amazing young folks out
there who want to get on board who want
to do this plan you know I'm glad you
said that and I I you know as a gen xer
you know middle-aged guy I I get a
little weary of people you know that
have poo pooed on the Millennials for a
long time and now gen Z which is you
know in the workforce you know they're
in their young 20s these are not
children anymore they're not but I will
also tell you that the younger
generation gen Z in particular is very
very conscious of the world around them
there's some really interesting Trends
just on what they believe about the
world and human value but then uh very
financially aware and responsible not
interested in debt that's why you're
seeing in some cases college enrollment
not in some cases it's dropping
dramatically and these kids are looking
at student loans they're looking at what
they've seen what they've grown up with
and they're going I don't know that I
want that and I think that plays into
why you're seeing a lot of young people
listen to the show uh in a previous hour
uh we had a 13 year old listen to the
show that's right and uh these kids want
a great future and they see being able
to be independent of anybody else and
financially secure and independent they
see it as something that is really
attractive so you're right it's
encouraged good on you young people uh
thanks for listening feel free to call
in he's shorts camel I'm Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me we're
thrilled that you're with us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Let's uh stay right here George in
our backyard Nashville Tennessee Allison
is on the line local how can we help
oh thank you for taking my call
um I just have a quick question about
what to do with some side hustle money
so a little bit of background my husband
and I both work full-time and have
salaries
um we have completed three baby step
three so we've got a fully funded
emergency fund no debt others in the
house so I started picking up some
freelance design work and I'm making
anywhere from 600 to 1200 a week I'm
wondering if yeah and so I'm wondering
if I should then take a portion of that
after I save of course a little bit of
that for taxes
um should I do 15 of the side hustle
money also towards retirement or should
I just take all of that and throw it
towards the house and try to knock it
out quickly
I love it I mean if you're if you look
at this as extra money and not part of
your traditional income I love the idea
of you getting intense on the house and
throwing it towards that
if you guys are on track for retirement
now if you look up and you go you know
what we haven't done a great job up
until now investing for retirement let's
use that money to max out the Roth IRA
to fully fund the 401K I'm good with
that too it's it's kind of a Choose Your
Own Adventure at that point
okay
you guys on track for retirement
so we are both investing up to our match
which is five percent in our 401K so
we're the next step is to up that to 15
oh you're not at 15.
no I'm saying with our salaries we'll do
15 but should I also do 15 of the extra
money
from the side hustle as well
yeah I mean I would say it's an option
and like you mentioned if you really
want to pay off this house then it's
totally okay to throw all that money
towards the house and like you mentioned
I would set aside 30 35 for taxes
absolutely because those will be a big
shock because you're making five grand a
month of self-employed income and the
government wants their piece of the pie
oh yeah oh yeah so maybe it is set aside
yeah you say that at the end of the year
you look up and we go all right we know
what we're going to be paying in taxes
or make sure you're doing quarterly
estimated payments to the IRS they love
that when you're making this kind of
side hustle money and beyond that I'd be
throwing it at the house and if you're
on track for retirement just use your
salary to invest 15 love it thank you so
much for the call Allison all right
Birmingham Alabama is where we go chance
is there chance how can we help
hey can you hear me yes sir loud and
clear
hey um I always had a question about
starting a business potentially and I
don't know how many details you need I'm
20 I just turned 29 my wife is 27. we
are debt free including our home
um we got some money put back I have
many talents I just don't know how to
Zone in on what I need to do
you talking about a career or a business
what do we what are we looking at
well just starting another starting a
business right now I'm I'm in uh X-ray
and MRI
um I work in Orthopedics so I didn't
know you know
I want to I kind of have a feeling I
need to start something but I don't know
what direction to go in yeah well let's
let's do this yeah yeah sure well I'm
just going to kind of dig a little bit
with you so have you had a few ideas
that tend to kind of keep popping back
up and you're just not sure about them
that's where I want to start what are
the ideas the business ideas that are
maybe the top one or two hit me with
them real quick
okay I am a journeyman plumber I'd have
to advance to a Master Okay in order to
go all the way with that
um what's the other I love I love
flipping things like buying and selling
stuff too like I feel like I do really
good in some area of that I love helping
people I like seeing progress all right
that's what I want to lock in on so
we'll we'll leave Plumbing to the side
and we'll leave flipping to the side and
when it comes to coming up with a
business idea I work with a lot of
people on this and and we start with who
are the people you most want to help I'm
going to ask you three questions that's
the first one who are the people you
most want to help the problem or desire
that those people have
and then the solution or solutions to
that problem or desire that you get most
excited about now when I walk you
through that your BR your brain began to
visualize some things and I want you to
just tell me describe the people that
you would most like to help
okay uh the people would be anybody and
that would be people that are looking
for something like they're searching for
whether it be a car whether it be
um you know some type of just something
for sale that they're looking for
um you know somebody in need of
something okay what are you whether it
be a tractor a car all right we got to
go deeper okay because the answer can
never be anybody all right because we
don't we don't start a business that
serves if I said to you uh hey I got a
friend who's got a business and you said
to me uh well that's cool so uh yeah
who's he served and I said everybody you
would be you know okay okay that's not
possible okay you get it now all right
so here's the deal yeah okay if you want
to get into sales all right if you want
to sell something in the in the form of
a product or a service okay
you still have to get clear on what that
is and then that will determine the
audience so we can back into this with
those three questions so if you what
tell me something I think I've heard the
answer I think I've heard cars but
something that you would get excited
about bringing to somebody as a solution
you helped him get this you'd feel
pretty jazzed about it what would it be
um
a deal I want somebody to get a deal on
something like they they feel like
they've got a good price on something
does that make sense I don't I'm trying
to it does answer the question I don't
know well you're thinking maybe you said
you heard it no I think you're thinking
too hard is what What's Happening Here I
think I know I can tell he's saying
you're a guy who's not uh lacking ideas
you're lacking decision like I gotta
decide I gotta drop anchor and uh so
what you're speaking to is is what I
call Mission results that you are
motivated by you are motivated to serve
people in a way that allows them to make
a quality purchase quality meaning it's
effective and it's cost effective I mean
it helps them and they got the best deal
possible and you were the conduit for
that am I right
yes sir all right so that means you're
going to be in the sales I think I think
a business where you are selling a
product or service so now your exercise
and I'm not going to make you do this on
the air but the exercise for you is to
determine what product or service that
you get most excited about which is why
I asked the question the people you most
want to help so if you can go well Ken
man I'm really excited about providing
um uh water relief or you know when
something floods or whatever you know or
I get I'm just making that up but then
we go okay well then who are the people
that you want to help well people who've
had some type of of disaster in their
home and they're freaking out and they
want to get a good person who they can
trust who's going to rip them off he's
going to come in there and help them get
the problem fixed you see how I backed
into that
yes okay yes so you're exercising your
homework assignment I'm going to give
you some tools to help you okay I'm
going to give you my get clear
assessment okay which is very personal
in nature but it's a 20-minute
assessment selling like crazy
ramseysolutions.com this assessment is
going to allow you to see what you're
most talented at
what you love to do and then the results
that motivate you in other words Talent
passion and Mission it's going to fill
out a purpose statement for you and
that's going to help you ideate business
ideas based on that purpose statement
I'm also going to give you my
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose which will help you in this
process but here's your homework
assignment besides taking the assessment
and reading the book I literally want
you to keep working through who are the
people that my business would help the
most make it real personal even though
we're brainstorming what is the problem
or desire that my business would help
solve
and then what would be the solution or
solutions that my business would provide
it's looking at the same thing three
different ways but it's where ideas come
from and you gotta trust your heart that
is throwing answers up at your brain and
you got to stop overthinking and coming
up with all the reasons why one idea is
better than the other I think you got
plenty of ideas you got to listen to
your heart and your heart's gonna tell
you sure what you most want to pursue
that's George a very simple way for how
people can begin to ideate on a
entrepreneurial venture because you
gotta care deeply about it because it's
hard and you can get the uh you know
analysis by paralysis paralysis by
analysis if we get stuck I don't know
what to do so I'm going to do nothing so
we have to act and figure it out on the
way George Campbell you're a gentleman
and a scholar wow thanks for hanging out
with me to the team behind the glass led
by James Childs our fearless producer
thank you thank you America this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your your
money specifically your budgets your
debt your work your opportunities
to maybe get that dream job and truly
live and give like no one else how about
your relationships we talk about life
whatever you want to talk about America
we're here for you I'm Ken Coleman
George Campbell joins me this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Terry is up in Temecula California Terry
how can we help
hey can you guys hear me okay loud and
clear
awesome pleasure speaking to you guys
today
um got a quick question regarding
um kind of a difficult work conversation
I'm going to have to have
um I'm an insurance agent I sell a
Property and Casualty so Auto home
um umbrella that type stuff
um and I just recently got my life
insurance license last week
um and so it's time for me to talk to my
boss about
um you know I I don't believe in whole
life or uh universal life
in line with what you guys
um you know kind of preach here and so
how should I have that conversation with
my boss and just kind of looking for
some ways in there yeah so before we
talk about how
what what's the point that you're going
to be making what's the very clear thing
you want your boss to hear don't worry
about how to word Smith it just tell me
Point Blank go
yeah I just want to make it clear that I
have no intention on on ever promoting
or selling Universal or whole life
insurance okay great and
are you required to offer or to sell it
in a and if you're talking to somebody
are you required is that something that
they're making sure you do or is it just
uh one product in a buffet if you will
yeah it's just one product in a buffet I
would say um so you're not required to
sell it the upper term insurance as well
I'm not required at all to sell it no
but I mean the expectation is there that
I'm asking about life insurance and and
pushing that which obviously I believe
in life insurance
um you know term insurance but yeah
um yeah and I understand the expectation
is there and I'm leading to answering
your question directly but I'm trying to
get true context here I understand the
expectation is there because it's one of
the products on the buffet if you will
okay but are they actively checking up
on this and monitoring this is this
something that you're going to have to
confront sooner or later
I I think I will have to confront it too
early all right so that's all I wanted
to know because you know to the point
that it's not like an aggressive thing
that you have to do I wouldn't bring it
up right now but if you're going to have
to deal with it sooner or later then
that's fine
um but what do you think the reaction is
going to be
I'm honestly not sure
um I've got a really good relationship
with the agency owner and it's a fairly
small agency that I work at uh there's
four of us in the office and
um you know I am the top producer in the
office as far as selling auto and home
great and so I'm not I'm not worried
about like losing my job per se but
you know I just I just want to make sure
I'm going about the conversation no I
got an opinion I got an opinion but I
but but I want to know one other
question so are the other products so
everything but whole life are they as
profitable for the agency his whole life
or his whole life more profitable
whole life is certainly the most
profitable that's what I thought all
right so you're gonna have to make a
business case on this and and when you
go in and I think you got to go in not
with a uh posture of uh being indignant
uh but just go in and be humble and and
very clear Hey listen just want you to
know
um I don't believe in this product I'm
not knocking you or anybody but I just
want to be up and up because I'm a
number one producer right now and I just
want to be very clear
um because it's going to come up
eventually why I'm not selling this and
I'm going to make the company a bunch of
money I'm going to make a lot of people
very happy and taking care of them but I
can in good conscious conscience
um uh sell whole life and now what you
can't do is get sucked into a debate but
if you've got a couple of key reasons as
to why you'd lay that out very clearly
and then sit back and it's almost like
you're just gently pushing that you know
that plate across the table and go this
is how it's going to be if you feel like
you got to confront it now that's the
only way to do this and let's just you
know I think the fact that you're a
number one producer and the fact that
you've got clear convictions as to why
you won't sell it I think I think it's
uh that's all you can do I don't know
that there's any other way that you can
handle that
got it got it how does that sit with you
Terry I mean you said you this may go
very smoothly and he goes all right um
it's understood you're not going to sell
a whole life and if someone's adamant
about wanting it you might pass it off
to a different sales guy who goes oh my
gosh thank you so much this is great
thanks for the lead but I love that
you're sticking to your convictions and
your values and thank you for The
Insider tip now we can announce To
America that the reason they push whole
life is because it's way more profitable
than term life that's what I was right
Terry can you can you confirm that for
all of us listening
yes that is correct but Terry now that I
answered your question I'm now going to
challenge you you okay with that
sure
while we do not like whole life
insurance at Ramsey Solutions and we're
very very clear on our stance on that
the fact of the matter is you have
chosen to work for an agency that sells
that product and they're not going to
stop selling that product I doubt that
you're going to lay this out and he's
going to go Terry you're right as of
today we're getting rid of whole life as
a product and we're not going to sell it
anymore we're going to talk everybody
out of it like that's not going to
happen right
right right so at some point you
probably need to be prepared to to go
out on your own or go with somebody else
who doesn't sell this product I'm just
telling you you I'm not knocking you I'm
just saying
this is a conflict here it's like
working in retail and they push the
store credit card and that's part of
your job is you got to do it and you
have to say listen I'm not going to push
the store credit card yeah it's like hey
I'm working for you but I don't want to
sell your number one product
see you're laughing
because part of me would go well then go
work somewhere else this is our number
one problem right so I don't know how
it's going to go hope it goes well but
at some point you probably need to go
somewhere else is what I'm getting at
that's that's what I think right exactly
and and that is something that I have
you know thought about
um you know eventually like you said
either striking out on my own or going
to you know a uh you know an agency or
somewhere else that that doesn't promote
it or with people who are more in line
with with my values
um but uh you know I mean I've only been
insurance for been in insurance for
about a year now and this is I mean this
is the first agency I've worked at and
so now that I have my life licensed the
expectation is that I'm going to be
selling life insurance and so I just
wanted to have that conversation on the
front end and get ahead of it yeah again
I love your integrity
but the the what you laughed at is the
point that you're going to have to deal
with which is it's like going to work
for an automotive dealer is they sell
one thing and you go listen I I'm not
going to sell this one I'm only going to
sell the used cars of the other make be
like what the crap are you doing here
so I mean understand that that's what
you're going to be met with and as I
understand that as much as I disagree
with whole life I understand why they
would react that way there's other
insurance fish in the sea and our
friends at Xander insurance for example
don't sell whole life
and so there are companies out there who
aren't going to push these products so
there's other options for you if this
doesn't work out but I hope the
conversation goes great and you're there
for a long time and you're very happy
yeah there you go that's simple but hey
be prepared to move on great reminder
that whole life is a rip-off from the
inside you heard it here first George
you're so spicy thank you wow hey more
of that coming right up this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman joined by George camel coming to
you from our Ramsey Solutions World
Headquarters and I got to tell you a
great crowd in the audience today in the
studio uh audience area our lobby it's a
lovely place and we give you free food
free uh cold and hot beverages baked
goods yeah it's a lovely Cafe when you
come in it's our gift to you because we
love when people come see us so it's a
reminder that we love when people stop
by just go to ramseysolutions.com and
you can check the schedule and we'd love
to see you and so we love to gift our
audience with that that's something Dave
you know has made a staple here uh and
then sometimes people uh nice people
give us stuff we go out and uh twice an
hour we we take pictures we sign books
and it was a lovely couple uh earlier
today George missionaries from the
Dominican Republic
and they just uh the team came in and
they gave us some coffee they both uh
they gave you and I a bag each of uh
some Dominican coffee and you love
coffee and I love coffee how many cups a
day uh I'm a two yeah yeah I'm about
four wow yeah oh yeah all before 11 A.M
if I'm not caffeinated I'm irritated
I'll tell you that much so anyway this
is very nice I'm holding a bag of Cafe
Santo Domingo and we teach generosity
around here so and sometimes we're the
beneficiaries of that and it gives us
great joy so there you go it's very kind
very nice people we we they did not tell
us their name so we're thanking them
publicly they were very humble about it
so thank you come visit us you don't
have to bring us anything we promise you
don't have to but we will do that for
like first season birthdays they go guys
no gifts no gifts yeah right but then
you're the one guy who didn't bring the
gift because everyone else you're the
one saying no gifts I say hey I'll take
your gifts Ken will take it I know this
you bring food if George won't eat it
James will that guy's never turn down
free food
like ever so there you go all right to
the phones we go triple eight eight two
five five two two five Drew is on the
line in Phoenix Drew how can we help
hey good evening afternoon guys
um I applaud your hearts in your
ministry thank you very much for what
you do thank you sir
I um quick question my daughter uh just
got into med school it's one of the more
expensive ones that accepted her so it's
90k a year whoa she's worked real real
hard for the last couple years while she
was making applications and and so far
this is the only one they accepted her
so of course she said yes she has about
25k in the bank she has no debt she
lives at home she drives a car that my
wife and I have provided for her as well
as insurance and gas and we gave her a
credit card for spending money we're
doing everything we can to help her out
so uh I encourage her to not use her 25k
towards her school but just to use it
towards de-stressing wherever she needs
to
and I just was kind of wanting to throw
that at you to make sure I'm not given
her horrible advice here
well I heard you mentioned that you got
a credit card for her
to cover expenses what's that about
okay so so
I I like I said I applaud your ministry
and I agree with with every bit of it
the credit card thing my wife and I have
a credit card we pay all of our
bills with our credit card and get the
airline miles out of it and every month
we have a zero balance on our credit
card so we're I don't know if that's
considered double dipping and I
understand why you can't encourage
people to do it who can't keep a zero
balance but that's just the way it works
for us
okay but here well here's I you can do
your plan that's fine you don't have to
agree with every bit of what we teach
but for your daughter right to give an
18 year old a line of credit who is
already broke and say just use it when
you need it that turns into five
thousand dollars of credit card debt
real quickly and I say that because I
was that guy
okay and so that's my worry for her she
is not she is not that guy she's 25 at
this point like I said it's taking her a
while to get in uh she has no bet that
we've paid for she's about to have a
whole lot of debt isn't she 360
000. yes
yes have you run that have you run that
number dad through your head have you
really thought through the amount of
that debt and how crushing that is and
how long that's going to take her to pay
that back
I don't know what the other option is if
her if her passion is to be a doctor but
yeah
the last you know the last seven to ten
years were there conversations about hey
I want to go to med school what's that
going to cost coming up with a plan of
how we're going to try to pay for that
have you guys saved up at all to help
with that has she been working to say it
sounds like this is just you woke up
overnight and went all right we're gonna
go 360 Grand in debt for med school and
it's the only option
that's that's a a valid criticism
um but can I push back too so no so
here's the deal there's really no answer
to that so so the issue is is that this
is the only school that she's gotten
into for a variety of reasons correct
correct but it's not the only med school
and I can guarantee you it's not the
um it's not the best option for her
because of the sheer cost do you
remember the last time you went to the
doctor you got a ballpark idea what that
was remember that
yes okay did you at any point before the
doctor examined you ask him or her to
show you their diploma you know where
they went to school yeah nope why
uh they they
pre-qualified with credentials just by
having a place
what but you trusted that just because
they have a doctor's office you just
went in there and you trusted your body
to them
uh well obviously with uh
consent to everything they were saying
yes right okay I'm but you see where I'm
going here nobody yes cares Drew where
your daughter gets her medical degree
from so I would I I would say if she can
get into the most expensive most
prestigious med school then she can
certainly get into the other ones and
it's time to read dial up and go okay
I'm not going to spend ninety thousand
I'm not going to go into debt ninety
thousand I'm gonna go to a place and I'm
gonna see if I can get it for half that
and then I'm 25 I'm a grown woman and
I'm supposedly so responsible that she
can make the money in cash flow her way
through it she's already got 25 in the
bank
so while she's in this med school your
recommendation would be for her to keep
applying to other Med schools no I'm
telling her not to go to this med school
I'm telling her to reapply and bust her
tail and buy the truth not the myth that
the medical school that you go to is any
indicator of your success
yeah again that is that is not that is
not part of the equation the the
equation as you said earlier was just
that why is it not part of the equation
once you applied to
because it's the only one that accepted
her yeah but but my point is why I want
to dig into why was that the only place
that would take her was it because of
her scores
not not her scores were average and
above
um but so the most expensive School
takes her but the other schools won't
you know what it was a it was a shock to
all of us I just don't think it's the
whole story dad but I'm just giving you
real advice I I I I just don't buy it
let me let me give you another
perspective on this I've got some
friends
who um had to take the LSAT I got
multiple friends who had to take the
LSAT to get into law school multiple
times multiple times and and where
there's a will there's a way and they
finally got in and and they did it and I
I just I don't buy the narrative that
this is the only option for her to go
into 360 000 worth of debt so I'm
challenging that George yeah uh it it
just still feels like we haven't talked
about this enough and I want you to sit
down with her you said she lives at home
right
yes okay I'm gonna help start this
conversation and gift you guys uh
borrowed future the documentary so hang
on the line Austin's gonna pick up and
we'll get you a link to watch that and a
code and here's all I'm asking you to do
sit down with her this weekend it's 88
Minutes watch this documentary and have
it spark a conversation
and you don't have to hope it's going to
spark a lot of questions because there
are some heartbreaking real stories
there's some inspiring stories we
uncover how the college system really
works and it really puts a bad taste in
your mouth about the whole education
system and there's a lot of villains in
the story from the student loan
companies to guidance counselors to
parents who are out of control but it
breaks it down in such a way that it's
hard to argue that going 360 thousand
dollars into debt is the right path for
anyone or the only path and what happens
if she doesn't graduate what happens
when she's in residency and can't pay
the bills and all of a sudden the dream
becomes the Nightmare and she can't buy
a house she can't start a family she
can't have kids that's where we're
leaving this generation when we're
putting them hundreds of thousands of
dollars in the student loan debt to
reach the dream
which becomes a nightmare is the irony
and uh well said George bar future we'll
show you the scary part of the back end
of it every parent needs to watch this
with their kids so true required reading
and watching thanks for the call Drew
hang on
hang on
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
George Campbell we are thrilled that you
are here with us we want you to find out
for yourself whyblinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more make
sure that you use the promo code Ramsay
to get the best deal today's question
comes from Brian in Texas I'm 21 years
old and I make 60k I've been informed
that if I stay in my current position
for just under two years I'll get a
raise and make 80k Should I stick it out
here and continue for the two years to
get the raise or should I continue to
look for a better paying position from a
different employer I'm saving for a home
and I'm trying to figure out the fastest
way to reach that goal it's a good
question and in a trade
um like this
um as a as a technician uh of some type
he just said Master it he'll be a master
technician yeah he mentions that in a
bigger question and so this is some type
of a trade uh and so what you've got to
make sure of Brian is that you don't
leave
uh an opportunity to move up long term
if you go somewhere else and let's say
that you're making 60 now and you go
somewhere else George and he makes 70.
but it's not as a it's not as good a
long-term prognosis by staying with his
current company if they're going to help
him be that Master Tech and he's going
to make that money and he sets himself
up to either run his own business one
day is what we hope so I'm okay with him
leaving
to get more money faster if he's
qualified to do so and it still sets him
up for his long-term goals to be that
master technician so that's that's the
answer there and you see this a lot
young people they really want that house
and they want to try to do it as soon as
possible but sometimes we can we can try
to do something too soon and it hurts us
in other areas yeah and you can't
microwave this experience and so if this
company is paying for this training for
him to become a Master Tech and he loves
this company I would stay there and the
kind of part of the bonus there is after
two years you'll get this nice raise
yeah so it's not a bad deal yeah have
you ever wanted to hear the most popular
calls that we take here on the Ramsey
show or do you love a good rant from
Dave yes we all love it those are all
rhetorical so far yes if you want to
listen to our take on current events if
you want to see and hear the best
debt-free screams that people love the
most we've got a new limited series
titled the best of the Ramsey show we
can get all those things and more we hit
on the current real estate market
investing and how to take control of
your life life and money and your work
in these crazy times you can find these
special episodes on the Ramsey Show
YouTube channels or on Spotify just
search for the best of the Ramsay show
the best of the Ramsey Show on YouTube
or Spotify you won't regret it check it
out now all right to the phones we go
triple eight eight two five five two two
five John joins us in Phoenix John how
can we help
um how are you doing today we are having
a blast what's going on
uh well I'm looking to purchase my first
home on minimal credit history
okay George is your guy I love these
conversations
it's what wakes me up in the morning oh
really bang coffee well give me some
advice here what do you mean by minimal
credit history
um well I've only had two credit cards
and I'm 42 years old I've only had two
Fortin credit cards one unfortunately is
on my credit right now as a negative for
about 600 and the other one I opened up
in April as a secured credit card for
three hundred dollars and since I've had
that I have paid uh half my balance off
15 days prior to my due date and then
the remaining balance three days prior
to my due date okay and where does that
leave you with a score have you been
checking your score
I'm at about a 585 right now okay how
much debt are you in total
uh probably about I'd say probably about
sixteen hundred dollars total not
including medical bills okay how much
are the medical bills
medical bills is probably about five six
thousand are you current on those are
they in collections
they're in collections okay because
we're gonna have to clean those up too
because all of this is dinging your
credit history which is not going to be
fun going to a mortgage lender saying
hey will you please lend me money
okay and so I'm I'm less concerned about
getting your credit score up is that
kind of your question how do I get my
score up so that I can qualify for a
mortgage not necessarily
um I mean I want to kind of avoid the
Sharks out there that just want to eat
people up and try to sell them something
that they can't afford
um and me and my wife's a cancer patient
so I take care of the family on my own
and I make about 88 000 a year with my
bonus included so I'm just trying to
find something because our lease is up
in March of next year and if I go rent
I'm gonna be paying over two thousand
dollars a month and paying for somebody
else's mortgage instead of paying for
for my own well I don't I don't buy into
that Mantra I think renting is buying
patience and I think it's really wise to
do and clearly you've already been
bitten by the Sharks because you're
sitting here in a pile of debt that's
affecting your credit history and so my
A1 for you is to pay off all of the debt
and that means negotiating with the
medical bills if they're older if not we
just gotta find them scrape the money
together to pay those off and get the
1600 hundred when you make 88 000 and
you're telling me your total debt comes
out to about six or seven thousand
correct so we can pay this off in a few
months
if we're on a budget we're pausing
investing we're getting gazelle intents
we're doing whatever it takes to get
this debt out of our lives for good and
George I've got a question on behalf of
John uh if he doesn't clean this up he's
not going to have the option of them no
you're not going to qualify renting is
all he's got or if he did it would be
such a horrible rate and horrible terms
so I I just want to make that clear
renting is his only option until he gets
us cleaned up if I'm in your shoes John
here's what I'm doing I'm going to pay
off all of my debt within the next three
or four months does that sound
reasonable
yes okay
after that you're completely debt free
we're going to get a fully funded
emergency fund in place do you have any
money in the bank right now
uh right now I have about fourteen
thousand dollars saved and within the
next couple a couple weeks I'll have
another eleven thousand dollars to add
on to that John why aren't we paying off
the debt today
because I was saving up for a down
payment on the house we're not ready for
that that would come later on after
we're completely debt free and have the
fully funded emergency fund in place
so I know we're excited about the home
but right now we're trying to do seven
things at once and we're not making
progress
and on top of that the down payment
money is no good if you can't get a loan
correct and so yeah you can't follow the
plan to a t here's what we're doing
we're paying off all the debt today you
have the money in the bank and you're
going to have some left over then we're
gonna restock that emergency fund to be
three to six months of expenses
and then your credit score over time
over the next 6 9 12 maybe 18 months uh
worst case will become indeterminable to
where the the mortgage company is going
to try to pull the score and they're
going to say we can't find one John is
invisible just like Ken was in high
school to girls
well played and so this may be a longer
term game but guess what that 18 months
that you're sitting there gives you a
lot of time to save up that down payment
doesn't it
yes it does and now this home can be a
blessing instead of a curse when you get
into it
okay so we have to reset our vision for
what that future looks like because you
were excited to get into a home you know
by March once this lease is up
but now it's looking like okay we're
looking at end of 23 before we're even
close to ready and so I want you to walk
into this with wisdom obviously you guys
have been through a lot you guys are
warriors man I'm proud of you guys
but I want you to focus on one thing at
a time so you feel the progress and so
that when you do get into this house you
breathe easy and you can afford the
mortgage very easily it's a quarter of
your take-home pay on a 15-year fix
because you have the diligence to get
rid of your debt so that you had your
greatest wealth building tool back in
your life your income
do you feel the peace that that brings
you
definitely definitely okay and you can
go check out my episodes of the fine
print we did one on the credit score we
did one on the housing market and what
that looks like and I talked to an
actual mortgage loan officer who talks
us through what it looks like to get a
house without a credit score and I speak
from experience John because I've done
this myself no score and I got a
mortgage it's possible and it didn't
kill me Ken I'll tell you A lot of
people go oh it's so much harder and
your interest rate is going to be nope
ran those numbers too and if you put at
least 10 percent down you do a 15-year
fix like we teach your your mortgage
interest rate is just as good as someone
with an excellent credit score so let's
put that one to bed too while we're at
it and uh to bring your uh jab full
circle can you tell them a little bit
about this Ken I uh you know I matured I
developed into a small size man and uh
married a beautiful woman and he's going
to have a beautiful house it turned out
great it did I saw you had to you gotta
you gotta sound the end of the story you
gotta go through the desert baby wow
yeah there's some silver lining on that
one well I had to bring It full circle
George thank you I'm just still wincing
in pain from that gym I'm sorry usually
I make fun of myself but I thought let's
try Ken today you can take it I can
handle it I thought it was well placed
sir thank you well placed hey John you
got this man do it the best is yet to be
don't move more Ramsey show coming right
up
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
show America I'm Ken Coleman Jordan
joined by George Campbell thrilled that
you are with us our scripture of the day
comes from first Thessalonians George
you got to say that one slow you you
can't rush in this uh low knee ends
there it is first Thessalonians 5 11
therefore encourage one another and
build one another up just as you were
doing
and we were doing that during the break
we were saying nice things about each
other we were yes after I ripped you in
the last segment yeah it was all good
came back good good good natured rubbing
uh our quote from Tony Dungy looked for
opportunities to share a word of comfort
and Grace with someone today perhaps
their story of what God has done in your
life hey I want to remind you if you
enjoy the show please consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with a friend the shows growing
bringing in new people all the time and
that helps us so thank you thank you
thank you if you would do that subscribe
review and share and uh we will be
grateful for it all right triple eight
eight two five five two two five Joe is
up in Oklahoma City Oklahoma Joe how can
we help
hey there guys my Dad recently offered
to buy me my wife a new car because he
would be leasing it
um I'm just really calling him to see
should we accept it and if we did how do
we go about that
I don't like almost anything about the
situation that's a weird form of
generosity because you're putting him
into debt is it in his name and you're
just driving it the title in your name
and the loans in his
so the title would be in his name
um no he would just be giving it to us
and we wouldn't have to make any
payments no no this is just no Haywire
man I would not accept this I'd say hey
appreciate the generosity uh it's very
kind of you but this is going to put you
in a precarious situation and we want to
own whatever we are driving and we want
it to be in our name and I appreciate
that if you want to gift us if you want
to write a check to help us purchase a
new car in cash or a used car in cash we
would love that but we don't want you
going into debt and robbing your future
for this gift
that's how I would put it as nicely as
possible
yeah okay what would he say to that
well I told him that and he he he just
replied back to accept it and to uh uh
yeah just to accept it so me and my wife
have just been talking about it there's
nothing real it's more of just in the
talks but knowing my dad uh it's very
possible it could happen and so
um how's he doing financially is he like
in an amazing spot would you say uh he
he is um I think he's in a good spot
um but now managing his finances is
another thing so I think that's why it
makes me worried yeah listen listen how
old are you
I'm 22. dude you're a grown man
yeah like that whole knowing my dad is
gonna happen and you're just resigning
yourself to it and I if you called us
for permission we're not going to give
you the permission if you called us for
verification that what you were feeling
is correct that he shouldn't do this you
don't want him to do this then you are
in fact right and you it's time for you
to man up and say pop I don't want it
I'm not going to take it and here's the
reason why thank you I'm very grateful
this is not a good Financial move for
you and I don't want to be a part of it
I don't need it
yeah do you have a car right now
yeah me and my wife both have two cars
paid off and they're fine yeah are you
needing to upgrade one
uh no I would love a truck but we don't
we don't need one so now let me just say
this Joe there's no you can't stop your
dad I mean if he goes out and puts a
lease in his name but but you don't have
to drive it and say hey I told you not
to do this I'm begging you not to do it
I'm not going to drive and then tell
them you're gonna have to pay the stupid
tax because you're gonna lose money on
this deal after you have to get out of
the lease right and I don't want that
for you what do you think is motivating
this Joe
I think um a little bit of it is that
whenever I was growing up she him and my
family weren't at the place that they're
at now financially and so I think now
one of the thing that plays into it is
he wants to
um you know kind of I guess
give me something we didn't have growing
up yeah um even though I wouldn't have
had a truck growing up regardless but
yeah I would acknowledge that when you
tell them say hey I appreciate what
you're doing and this is awesome and I'm
but it it I don't regret anything I
don't resent you you know like I would
add some of that to this conversation
you know and if he wants to do something
smaller for you say hey there's other
ways that you could bless us that that I
think are you know much more financially
responsible maybe uh Jello of the month
club you know I don't know is that a
real thing the gift that keeps on giving
isn't it Christmas Vacation nobody wants
that gift no nobody does it's my point
like you don't need to bless us dad like
you don't have to give us something do
you know you raised me to be independent
and I'm a grown man now and I want to do
this on my own and own it and really
feel the ownership and I feel like if
you gifted to us we're not gonna be able
to do that yeah and so if you want to
write us a check later on in life that
can help go towards that truck I'd love
that but no pressure yeah just take the
the like you don't have to do this dad
you know yeah and yeah and that I think
hopefully comes from a spirit of
gratitude and humility and hopefully
that'll work so tough stuff though yeah
appreciate the call yeah thank you
that's uh a dad who means well
and but creates a really awkward
situation and then obviously a bad
financial situation for himself how many
calls do we get where the kids are going
hey my parents didn't take care of
themselves financially and now we have
to right and that's what I see in the
next 20 years for this guy absolutely
let's go to Jacksonville Florida Gary is
there Gary how can we help
yes sir hi uh this is a first time
caller and uh I'm just I'm just from the
back patio right now uh working on this
generator getting it ready to basically
uh just in case the power goes off hey
me and Ken have been there man
yeah uh we just don't know what exactly
what this phone is going to do yet well
I hope you guys stay safe is it in your
past yes sir
yes yes it's supposed to be up up in
this area sometime tomorrow all right
how can we help we don't want to take
you away from that generator
uh yes sir um I'm I'm 61 years old and
uh and I'm actually going to a a
financial advisor next Friday but I'm
wondering if I should just
um I'm thinking about returning the next
year and a half two years and I'm
wondering if I should just go ahead and
take the money out go ahead and pay my
taxes up front and be done with it and
be done with the stock market
what should I do
um and that's a great plan if you plan
on running out of money in the next 10
years
uh do you plan to live past 70 I hope so
I hope so yes sir uh I would leave that
money in there growing Gary don't do
that you're you're afraid because you
see the stock market news every day Gary
let's say you you live to 90. right
that's that's a high possibility
yes sir over the next 30 years do you
think the stock market is going to be in
a better place than it is today 30 years
from now looking at the track record of
the last 30 years
it should the answer is yes
unequivocally yes yes yes yes yes and so
what happens is if you stay invested in
the stock market that money is going to
grow and you won't drain the principal
you know because what happens is when
you cash out today and you start taking
you know withdrawing to create an income
for yourself that money is just sitting
there flat instead of growing
and that's how people run out of money
in retirement yeah so I don't want you
to be fearful I would contact a smart
investor Pro don't just meet with any
old financial advisor and they will help
talk you off the ledge show you the
charts and graphs and show you what the
next 30 Years will look like if you
leave your money in Gary here's the deal
you haven't lost any money I know that
you're looking at your statement the
value has dropped but you haven't lost
it because you haven't pulled it out and
let me just tell you the stock market as
you know is a big money game and and I'm
telling you that there's a lot of money
on the sidelines right now because of
recessionary issues inflationary issues
all the stuff that's going on and the
people that are big money in the stock
market that drive the price the ups and
the Downs they've pulled their money out
for a season they're going to put it
back in and every month when you are
contributing your 401k you are buying
stocks and everything you've had so far
at a great discount and when it goes up
you are going to cash in Gary so hang on
stay on the roller coaster nobody gets
hurt unless they jump off hang in there
be safe take care of that generator hope
the storm doesn't hit you too hard hey
George Campbell great stuff good stuff
to James and the crew behind the glass
you guys rock
to you America we do the show for you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]